okay good afternoon everyone um the
program on the main stage continue we
have a super exciting talk now with Andy
about uh prompt evaluation so Andy is a
AI researcher founder of cical lab and
working also at explosion Ai and we are
super happy to have him so yeah let's
Applause
him all right hey everyone how you going
um the this talk is promptly evaluating
prompts so if you meant to see a
different talk you're in the wrong room
uh people are still coming in so I guess
I'll warm up the crowd a little bit so I
always start all my presentations with a
joke so here's one never been heard
before this is new just for you I came
up with it uh the night before we left
so uh there's this um there's this AI
researcher and he's just died and he's
ended up in hell and uh he sees the
devil there and the devil is giving him
a tour because of course every new
arrival in hell gets a tour so he's
taking him around and show him the
different rooms and they walk into this
room and in the room is Sam Alman and
and he's got these wires coming out of
his head he's like half merged with a
machine he's hybrid you know he's like
half human half machine and all these
wildest dreams are coming true he's
living his fantasies he's giving
presentations he's flying like a bird
whatever it is and uh the AI researcher
looked in the room and says hey you know
that doesn't seem so bad and the devil
says oh no no no this isn't the room we
used to punish Sam mman this is the room
we used to punish the
AIS okay get a clap thank you thank you
all right all right so the title of this
talk actually should have been basy and
Thunderdome but I didn't know the like
visual concept of the talk when I
submitted it so it got a really dry
title imagine it was called basy and
Thunderdome okay so you got a bunch of
prompts because you love llms or you
love stable diffusion or whatever it is
and you need to know which one is better
and right now often at least when I
started doing this and I've seen a lot
of other people do it they just kind of
like try things and so it's sort of like
trial and error and sort of Vibes but I
I want to do a little bit of audience
participation so maybe like raise your
hand if you've been doing like you've
written a prompt recently yeah yeah okay
whoa that's I guess this is the right
place for it okay um maybe maybe someone
over there we've got we've got our
helper he'll bring you a microphone you
can pick someone no he's just this is an
AV thing okay well while we're waiting
um we'll go okay uh how about you were
you have you done a prompt yeah no no
yes behind behind Vincent yes she's yes
I'm talking to you yes blonde
lady like any prompts any prompts uh
yeah I okay this embarassing ing but I
as to I also to write like birthday
cards yeah
really that's said were they good uh
yeah they were pretty good was it for
friends you like or friends you don't
like for friends I
like nice uh so how did you get it to
write in a good
style
um I just posted like the personality or
not personality like a birthday card for
a friend this age and I'm giving this
gift um
put in a joke or something amazing yeah
the the joke didn't really work that's
no you know LMS don't really do humor
very well it's a thing this is more
research into this so um did you do
trial and error or did you do anything
clever with picking the prompt um no
well I I just did one prompt and then it
gave me something and I could just write
it down one hit wonder I like it yeah
yeah okay true story I actually had a
large language model generate part of a
speech for one of my friends weddings so
there you go but this was before they
were good and everyone was really drunk
so it was very funny okay maybe we do
one more okay how about um down there
curly hair brown curly hair you can pick
one helper can pick one he doesn't want
to someone else come on who did a prompt
put up your hand yeah we're going to
pick on you nobody's putting their hand
up now they like I'm going to be picked
on oh here we go we got one he's Keen
he's
Keen uh yeah I I had a issue where I
want to pie wear a piece of code uh and
I asked to write the piece of code but
it wrote it different than I expected
yeah uh I I had an idea part of it get
the llm to do your job for you
like and then i' read about this um uh
this decision discussion or something
and you had to tell like okay I thought
you would go that way can you have a
conversation between three seniors
reviewing a piece of code which is
either that way or that way it was very
nice like pretend to be three experts I
like it very nice see and did that
technique work better yes very well
actually because the one expert took the
suggestion from the AI the one expert
took my ID and the third one came with a
middle ground which I might have thought
of after a couple of hours thinking but
it actually came out to something new
that's very good that's very good but do
you know objectively if it was better no
there we go okay so that's why you need
this talk okay so here it is uh we have
generative models and uh they are hard
to object uh evaluate objectively so
looking at a prompt knowing if you'll
get a good answer you'll get a good
birthday card you get a program that
works is very very difficult Alchemy
secondly um even if you trying to
evaluate the outputs so for example a
piece of writing or a picture it's hard
to say you know on a on an absolute
scale how good this thing is and it's
much much easier to say I'm going to
choose between two things so that gives
us this sort of interesting problem
formulation so we have many choices
we have sort of paired comparison so
instead of picking one thing like you
would in a multi-arm bandit or something
like that we have two things that we
compare uh finally we have noisy
outcomes so obviously if we compare two
things the even if one is better it
won't win all the time and finally uh
we're going to assume transitivity here
this is normally pretty reasonable but
it just means if a beats B and B beats C
then we assume a is going to beat C and
we can get a lot of uh performance
Improvement because of that and there's
some extensions where we don't have to
assume this but they're not super
important we also want to add new
options at anytime so uh if we're
iteratively working we might find some
inspiration we might change the present
we bought whatever it is and uh we need
to add those at a later stage and if
we're doing something simple like
comparing them and just counting how
many times they've won you have a
problem which is you kind of have to
start with all the things you wanted to
compare from scratch but we really do
also want to add late entries at any
time or remove things that you don't
like later so you want it to be an
iterative process where you're
constantly comparing adding things kind
of you have a stable of things you like
you introduce some new ideas and you
want to see how they shape up and we
want to do that all
fluidly so there is a solution to this
problem that is both ma mathematically
elegant and fairly well um theoretically
supported so I'm calling it the G Glick
best algorithm which has developed
recently so you're hearing about it here
first it's a novel and um it's basically
this thing called gcco or gcor ratings
plus an exploration maximization step
and I'm going to explain how those two
things work how those two things work
together and why they'll make your
prompts
better
so uh oh I also have to add that um all
these images are generated with stable
diffusion I think some are most are sdxl
so there you go it it blows my mind you
can get photos of like movies that never
existed like you can imagine like
something cool is happening there like
maybe there's a story but there you go
so
gcco uh developed by a statistician
named Mark Glickman thank you and there
are two fundamental parts to the glicker
rating you have your rating which is a
number that's like 1,500 or something uh
it's a close relative of the ELO scoring
system which is used in chess and
several other sports uh you also have a
ratings deviation so that is basically
the standard deviation of your rating
how sure we are that you have a
particular or a player has a particular
skill and finally GCO has a closed form
update which is just really useful
because it means we don't have to do any
uh complex uh sort of stepwise like
iterative optimization to update gcor
ratings after someone whims or
loses so uh GCO is a Bradley Terry model
which is Jon but uh intuitively or not
so intuitively the odds are some kind of
uh here we go power 10 function of the
difference between the rating of J and
the rating of I or the two players so
rating i j is the rating of your two
players this can be when you look at it
a little bit hard to see the intuition
behind but when you see a table it's
very clear so on the left we've got the
rating difference between sort of two
options and then you have the odds of
winning and you have the percentage
chance of winning so you can see at a
100 Point difference you should be the
the sort of leader should be winning 64%
of the time a 200 Point difference
should be 76% of the time and you can
also see where this power 10 comes in so
intuitively a 400 Point difference is a
10 to1 odds and a uh 800 Point
difference is a 100 to1 odds so this has
got a kind of um low it's a low jit
basically uh and finally we have a way
to update ratings and also updating
their uncertainty so we've got our basis
which is we can rate things and we can
know how uncertain we are about how good
something is but there's still a missing
piece and that missing piece is that the
glyco system itself doesn't tell us what
two things we should compare next so
what we really want to do is choose
something that's going to do clever
things most of the time and this is a
pure exploit sorry pure exploration
problem so often algorithms have uh
exploration or exploitation this is your
classic tradeoff and things like um
multi-arm Bandits or whatnot in this
case there is no particular cost to
comparing two things or two bad things
uh we would just like to learn as much
as possible as quickly as possible so
this takes on a very sort of pure
exploration
formulation so the answer is BDS them
which is basy in decisions using
sequential matches well we are in
Amsterdam so I need a needed a joke for
that
so the the key idea here is that uh
intuitively if we have two things that
have similar ratings we're most unsure
about who will win so finding out the
outcome of that comparison will give us
the most
information secondly we would like to
know who's best so that means we want to
compare who's best
to the person who would be most likely
to be sort of second best or most likely
to be best were it not for the first one
existing so we want to play that against
the second most likely to be first and
this is where the sort of basian magic
comes in because this is very subtle the
runner up so the thing with the second
highest rating is
not the one with the it's not the one
with the high the second highest
probability of being first and I'll show
you how that works
so here we have the sort of bell curves
of three options visualized so we have
the blue player the green player and the
purple player and in this case it's very
clear that the blue is the presumptive
favorite although there is uncertainty
there it's fairly clear that the second
best so to speak is this green one and
then we have this purple one who's in
third and so we would try and play off
the blue one and the green one in this
case to find out more about who's really
best and remove some of that that
uncertainty but what about this
situation so this is where we're much
more uncertain about the purple player
so clearly the blue player is still the
presumptive favorite
but which one is sort of the second
highest probability of being first the
green player or the purple player when
you look at where the probability Mass
actually lies this purple player has a
much higher chance of being number two
than the than the green player because
when we're much more we're much more
uncertain about how good it is so you
can kind of see when we're more
uncertain about something it says oh
there's a possibility that this one
could actually be the best so in this
case lick best the algorithm would play
off the blue one against the purple one
and learn kind of as much information as
possible about which one is
better so practically what does it look
like and we can do sort of some
empirical head-to-head comparisons about
like which how this
performs so here we have a very like an
illustrative situation so we have eight
options there's an 100 Point rating
spread between them so each option kind
of going up the ladder is 100 points
higher than the next that means it has a
60 something per chance of beating the
one sort of above it or below it and um
we have three kind of reasonable options
so one is random pairs that means you
just took a random pair of things and
you see which one wins and and then you
just count up who has the highest score
at the end like who won the most
matchups and if you did that after 35
comparisons you would actually choose
the true best 40% of the time or a
little bit less than 40% of the time you
could do a single elimination tournament
where you pair things up and the you
know winner stays on the loser drops out
and you could do that several times over
and record which one which player wins
the tournaments kind of most times in a
row and if you did it that way you would
choose the true best about 60% of the
time and if you were to use the Glick
best algorithm you're getting as high as
80 so it's significantly better than a
sort of simple-minded tournament and
part of the reason is is because it's
not wasting any time comparing things
that aren't going to possibly be the
best um because it really focuses on
learning information about the best and
second best presumptive player over and
over again which does make it a little
bit greedy so the other huge benefits of
doing this which I think is uh even if
it wasn't more accurate this would be
huge which is it allows late entrance so
if you're doing any iterative
development at any time you just add a
new Option you set its skill to 1,5 or
rating to 1,500 you set its ratings
deviation to like 300 so you say I don't
really know much about this thing and
will naturally get folded into
comparisons um you get ratings for every
option so um even though it's not
optimized for uh even though it's not
optimized for full ranking it still does
a very good job of giving you an idea of
still how what the lay of the land is
and you don't get that out of a lot of
other approaches and that uh sort of
entire ratings list is updated each time
you um have comparisons and then finally
you get a ranking probability so you can
ask what is the probability that this
thing is first and you could keep
comparing until that thing says you're
95% confident that this thing is first
or 99 or whatever it is so it gives you
a natural stopping condition as
well um there's some extensions and
variants that you could be interested in
one is to use Thompson sampling instead
of this rank uh second highest
probability of rank one approach BDSM um
many way comparisons currently this is
set up for doing um AB comparison so
comparing two things at a time and um
you might want to maximize your total
ranking information if you care about
the whole ranking not just the thing
that's best and there there some natural
extensions to do that and you also might
want to spread the load a little bit so
if you're worried that um various things
might fatigue or like like if you
actually comparing physical objects
testing them might actually you know
damage them or they might be players
they actually get tired you can't
compare the best thing with the other
thing like all the time over and over
again so you might want to model that
but in the case of prompts luckily
prompts never get tired we can just keep
making cool
pictures so some observations Glick best
is kind of sticky and this is good and
bad because it's really trying to
squeeze out every little bit of
information you can get from every
comparison but that means it's often it
will spend a lot of time just comparing
the presumptive favorite with like the
thing that is obviously second best
because that's all it cares about you
could spread that out a little bit um
and there's no look ahead so in the very
low comparison situation like if you
have eight options and you're only going
to do seven comparisons this doesn't do
much better than a single tournament
simply because without any look ahead
you you can't do the smart things but it
also means it's an anytime algorithm so
wherever you stop it you'll get a
reasonable answer you don't have to
ahead of time know how many rounds
you're going to compare
for so where can I get Glick best you're
asking me because you all do prompt
stuff and you all need to uh compare
your promps objectively and efficiently
so uh there is a GitHub repo with a
minimal uh reference implementation
there the URL there uh send me a line if
you end up using it for something I'd
love to hear it uh oh it is also in the
explosion AI Prodigy product there is a
whole Suite of prompt engineering tools
which this is a small Corner because of
the amazing work of the uh Prodigy theme
so um uh you can try that out right now
this is an example you can set up this
llm tournament uh with your different
llm prompts and you'll get a face like
this if you've used this product before
you'll know what I'm talking
about uh cool so this is this is a very
tight talk so I'm I'm happy to take your
questions thank you
please oh we got
one I feel like I should be more funny
while this is
happening oh well I should I I line up
two jokes next time so example for for
the birthday cards how would you
actually apply this yeah absolutely it's
a great question imagine that I have uh
sort of three prompts and the first
prompt is write me a birthday we'll call
it the vanilla General so we'll say
write me a birthday card they are this
years old and I got them flowers and
that would be very dry you can imagine a
second one which would be like I love my
friends so much and I really want to
tell them how much I love them and I
want you to be really emotional about um
riding a card and I've got them flowers
and this years old but I I want them to
feel like they're really young and
really excited that they're you know and
then you want another one which is like
okay you know I wanted to be quirky and
funny so you might write a prompt which
is the quirky funny prompt which is why
write me a fun uh birthday card with
lots of puns and humor they are turning
this age and then you would say okay
which one is better which one do I like
most and so just by looking at them you
can't really tell maybe the jokes are
bad maybe the emotional one comes out as
insincere something like that so then
you would get from those three prompts
generations and you would compare them
so the algorithm would pick a pair for
you to compare and You' say oh I like
this one and then you'd say I like this
other one and then you would keep going
and eventually the one that was best
that you preferred the most would have
the highest ranking and then you could
go on to build your billion dollar
birthday card generation
startup I hope that made sense yes okay
good we can have we have the time for
heaps of questions I'll probably finish
early yeah yeah uh hi thanks uh for your
presentation
and also for the Sable diffusion
generator
pictures um so my my doubt is about a
bit uh where does the ban part comes in
because it was a bit unclear whether the
distributions you were showing were like
for instance posterior distributions and
if they are how do you define your
priors yeah excellent question excellent
question so let's go back to that slide
because I think this is the one you
talking about right so this is a
posterior distribution uh your in this
case case your posterior is three normal
distributions over the ratings of your
individual uh choices um
furthermore in this particular case it's
a you know it's a basian update right so
not only is this the posterior now so
not only is this is the prior for this
is the prior for the next route so this
is the posterior after a number of
comparisons and when you do the next
comparison you'll update your beliefs
and you'll end up with a posterior over
ratings which will be your new prior ET
ET Etc so um this is both the posterior
after the last comparison and the prior
for the next comparison because it's a
basian update secondly um in this
particular
thing if you were to write out a Bradley
Terry model and build like a proper say
um like Mark of chain Monte Carlo
sampler you would not have exact bell
curve
posteriors the reason why they're bell
curves is because one of the main kind
of clever approximations in the glio
approach is to say well okay we're going
to uh assume that our posterior are Gan
shaped and this is not exactly a correct
assumption but it's an excellent
approximation and it also makes prior
specification extremely easy so I was
going on about how easy it is to
introduce um new entrance if you have a
prompt you like uh you can just bring it
in at like a 1,700 rating and you can
throw in a reasonably large um spread on
it and it will start getting compared to
the best thing right away uh so it's
very easy to put in whatever beliefs you
want and in fact uh if you have some
reason to believe that uh there is some
shift in variance so some shift in
ratings over time which um could be
quite likely if you're comparing things
which actually age or become less
popular or whatever it is you can just
go through and add more ratings
deviation to every option and that will
increase your uncertainty across the
board and all the questions you would
ask would still be coherent so one of
the amazing things about having such a
simple posterior approximation is that
it's effective but also very easy to
specify yeah that's an excellent
question thank
you I have I have actually one more joke
which
is we're all gcos
now
uh yeah I'm not sure which one you meant
to talk about but I can think of two
types of ways of talking about
strategies you can have like a very simp
specific sentence three different
versions for a speciic problem or you
can have this General IDE like I'm going
to try a quirky one I'm going to try an
emotional one I'm going to try a bland
vanilla one like or very speciic sens
does this strategy work for both can you
can you also do it with vager strategies
to evaluate if the strategy as a whole
is better than
another yeah that's a that's a really
really really good question so um maybe
I will sort of talk about uh variance so
you just gave me an idea you're a smart
man uh one of the things that's a really
big hot thing is um hierarchical basian
models so this is very very flat and
that no information is shared between
prompts so if I have two prompts that
are very similar but for a small change
we expect if one is good then the other
would also be good and there's no sort
of information transfer there so you
could imagine a hierarchical system
where you have a model and it says okay
so I have various different like themes
and the theme could be like approach or
you know an a motion or something and
then within the themes I draw a skill
and then for each option within the
theme I drew I draw like a skill um
noise Factor um so a per class or per
category parameter so you could
absolutely imagine a fairly natural
extension of this which has like uses a
hierarchical basian model to give you
both category skills and then also
individual skills um and that would be
that would be a super cool extension to
do so I think the answer is in its raw
form all options are equal there's no
information shared between them but
there would be natural extensions which
bundle them up into the categories and
themes super good question though other
questions yeah yeah okay we got another
one this is like high quality audience I
have to say you you you all are the best
I'm glad I I'm glad I left time for
questions I yeah thanks a lot for the
talk it was amazing um but I have one
question so writing three promts sounds
like a lot of work could you see like an
option to just write one and let it
let's say create some creative new prom
promts that you then so from from like a
simple scenario setting create maybe 20
many different prompts and then when it
youo drops of one of the prompt to uh
let's say Baseline level you just kick
it out create a new one based on the
initial scenario something like that
yeah thank you for coming um uh this is
like the master class in asking good
questions the questions are better than
my talk so um yeah one of the absolutely
awesome things about this approach again
with um late entrance is that it's very
easy to abolt on a thing which like you
might write a meta prompt which is given
three prompts write me some new prompts
right so the the input would be your
prompts and the alpha would be new
prompts and we were just playing with
this like for a demo right before
so it works really well and also the
late entrant thing allows you to just
throw some more prompts into the mix
maybe that you didn't even write that
you generated it and then start
evaluating them right away so it's
really harmonistic with any way you get
prompts whether you write them yourself
you use llms to generate them from other
point prompts or maybe like just from
nothing um and you know you you may have
if anything one of the things that makes
this so important is that it's really
quick to generate prompts but uh now
you've got too many prompts like you
could ask gbt to give you like a dozen
prompts but what are you going to like
click through like cut and paste each
one individually and be like is this one
good and you generate one and you're
like I don't know seems okay so this
gives you a really really rational and
efficient way to then say actually which
one do I want to use for my product or
service or whatever it is or my research
paper as the case may be but man I thank
you for your questions this is so good
um and I will say if you want to see a
demo of it running with some of those
ideas you should go to the the explosion
Booth it's just on the left hand side in
the middle you can use it live or that
the implementation of the algorithm okay
um we have time for one more question
last question is
there
it's great sorry for making run um
really simple question compared to the
others Could you actually put up the
eurs again so we can take a look at
those that's an easy one to answer but
the most important one yeah there we go
you can take photos of that one Andy
kitchen Glick best click best that's the
name of the algorithm that's the name of
the repo don't wear it out and then
people are still taking photos okay and
I will actually end on a joke because I
I I thought of the B joke that I didn't
use but so I do have two jokes in fact
and no more cameras out I see okay so
the last one is uh produ g produ dog
features prompt engineer you can also
take a photo of
that okay so final closing
joke um how many large language models
does it take to change a light
bulb one to write the prompt and a human
gig work to actually go and do it
thank
you thank you
eny thank
you